come on rules it's the best if you don't
like Pokemon you're wrong
[Music]
we're gonna open some surprise Pokemon
bags I'm very excited I've been waiting
for this we have been waiting we've been
waiting for this for weeks
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
I think it's red yeah okay I think so
Totodile Chikorita
oh my god that's so it's so many now I
feel like I'm leaving one out yeah I
think it's 20 but it feels too round I
feel like I'm forgetting something I'm
gonna say 17
I got I'm gonna say psych up to it's
fighting I think
that is very vain so I say spiritomb can
I say gastly oh my god
no I say water but I think that's
incorrect I'm gonna say flying psychic
dammit that's right because I remember
gonna like yeah cause it should be water
that's why it was I was like I know it's
not water I'm gonna say ride horn or
ride on or mu am I trying to do logic
and think about like what their numbers
are which is why I think nu is a good
guess right yeah so like Charmander
squirtle and Bulbasaur I don't I feel
better look at her she's so sad there is
so much stuff in the back oh my god oh
it's a patchy tail oh my gosh are you
gonna wear it around a little clutch
hole respect I'm sorry whoops that's
really cool oh my cool could it be a
look at the time
oh I think it is the game should have
been guessed with this Pokemon she would
have won for sure oh my god these are
great oh my god
[Music]